so maybe that's earlier maybe that's  like i mean that's your favorite you can  look at all this destin was really great  in kind of grounding me in what  this movie was really about we know that  this guy is going to be a fighter  probably one of the best fighters that  we've ever seen but what's more  important than that is what he's going  through  who is sean what drives him to do the  things that he does and in what ways  will he find himself over the course of  this movie focusing on that made all the  rest of it all the marvel part of it not  seemed so daunting  the one thing that we wanted to draw on  from the comic books was really the idea  of chongqi's difficult relationship with  his father that i think destined was  really keyed into he really made when  woo a very sympathetic character but  also a very real villain in a way that  that felt like an evolution of the  source material we will rebuild the tan  reigns to what it once was  you